you're not supposed to go and lift
weights and come out and go hmm
feel like a protein snack pass me the
pork scratches oh yeah if one of the
fighters fighting one of your cards was
eating them pre-fight would you be
saying i mean can you imagine
you know he's like he's in the hotel
lobby and i'll walk over all right man
we got there i'll be able to pull
scratchings what's going on
[Music]
hi this is eddie hearn and this is snack
wars for sports bible and it's us versus
uk snacks do you like america um
i do like america i mean it's different
level in it it's different levels of
obesity for me that's good
oh
naughty but i'm absolutely starving so
we got a big mac
and my mouth is watering and we've got a
sausage roll what a great day
[Laughter]
[Music]
so good show off
i've never had a big mac what's your
order with about four pounder of cheese
and the normal burger
and i've grown to love the gherkin i
think it's a necessity
to be honest with you it's still warm as
well
only the best i've never had a greg
sausage rock
hmm
[Music]
it's a tough one actually but i've been
eating all day and that first bite was
epic i'm gonna go for the big mac oh
that was really nice
i'm on a real strict diet and haven't
eaten all day that was so nice
i feel like you need a bigger clutch
okay
so we've got a nice bud all nice and
cold as well but it has to be so cold a
beer
never really liked budweiser what do you
think of american beer in general poor
i like the bottle beers in america so
like mikkel of light cause light
all the real hardcore stuff
then we got the scrumpy jacks
quite emotionally attached to scrumpy
jacks
because in my first ever job i used to
represent sportsmen and one was ian
botham obviously the cricketer and my
first ever deal that i did was with
scrumpy jacks and ian beaufort
it's fascinating i mean this
like i'm not really a cider fan if
there's anyone out watching
this who's my age or anyone in here you
remember k cider which was the black
bottles with the reds like that you used
to take four or five of those to a house
party
gone
oh that is absolutely dreadful i'm sorry
we've got to go to the usa
okay this is my go-to in the hotel lobby
pork crackling really it's kind of
become like a health food 18 grams of
protein and only 134 calories but will
clog up your arteries all day long
i really like i really like this but
when i eat this such things myself
what part of a towel is that
when you look at those you know it can't
be
smelled terrible
like
funny enough if you went into a pigsty
yeah right that is what you'd smell do
you remember
before everyone went healthy and they
just had the mr porkys and you knew they
were filth
you know
so you ate it and you went these are
just so bad for you i kind of feel these
ones are a bit confused
so they're like
we're trying to make this a protein
health snack but at the end of the day
it's still pork scratchings that's not
what pork strappings are meant to be
you're not supposed to go and lift
weights and come out and go hmm
feel like a protein snack pass me the
pork scratches oh yeah if one of the
fighters fighting one of your cards was
eating them pre-fight would you be
saying i mean can you imagine
you know he's like he's in the hotel
lobby and i'll walk over all right maybe
we got there i'll be able to pull
scratchings what's going on that's okay
because they're 18 grams of calories
only 134
see what you're trying to do
but i'm a bit old school
for me
the beef jerky gets the win
oh
my dad
loves licorice
i think they're one of the most
disgusting things
ah smell
awful
[Laughter]
so bad
natural colors and flavours
so natural
might come out the ground i'm not sure
awful but what is this oh
toxic waste green sour candy
jesus christ
jesus sour
okay yeah
that is unbelievably ranked i never ever
thought i would say this in my lifetime
i'm going with a licorice all sorts
which is absolutely revolting
versus this toxic waste thing that
should just be banned from all stores
oh this is
this is bad news for the uk because i
hate twiglets these are serious crisps
and i'm very passionate about crisps
like if you were to put monster munch
there
i wouldn't have even opened them they're
not twiglets
awful it's a bit like pretzels you know
like plain pretzels
i don't understand
who would buy them how can you eat that
and go ah
twiglets mmm my favorite
sorry
are they but look this is what i'm
saying about america look at the size of
that
now if that was a whatsit it would be
half the size
[Music]
every trip to america
i eat these no like in the hotel lobby
they've got that little shop they've
always got cheetos in it
this is an absolute drubbing
i'm gonna have to go with the us don't
ever come around my house with twiglets
always come loaded with cheetos right
come on we must be sort of dessert time
yes
absolutely awful the worst chocolate you
could possibly get is hershey's kisses
now
these are the governor when you go into
the petrol station and they're like you
see the magic sign
one pound for the snack bags you're like
minstrels
galaxy whatever though you know like the
smooth minstrels as well buttons
you know when you
find some chocolate that you hid like
four years ago
in your house and you eat it that's what
they taste like
i love chocolate
is that your vice
bad yeah
really bad
take them away
buttons for the win uk baby i feel bad
saying it but it was a big victory usa
for the win
i actually feel sick
started off so well like
when you get onto the misses
you've been drinking today on a tuesday
it's like no i swear what it was was we
were doing this snack war she's like oh
god
[Laughter]
what's this
okay let's have a little go of this